I thought it would honestly be really
funny if I read my blog post naked.
That's writer Cathy Reisenwitz. On the day that she sat down for an interview with Reason,
she had been posting photos and videos to the website OnlyFans for about two weeks.
One of the goals that I have for my OnlyFans is to get more people exposed to my writing.
I've been writing about sex for a long time, my blog is called Sex and the State,
and I am very big on sex-positive feminism which holds that sex is inherently morally neutral.
OnlyFans is a social network like Instagram or YouTube,
except the creators get to charge for their content. Nudity is both allowed and a common feature.
I think there's also this kind of dualism where you're like that kind of girl, you're not that kind of girl,
like you're either someone who makes money from their brain or their body and I think that's dumb.
So when I saw some women who I respect intellectually start their OnlyFans, I thought,
that's a trend I'd like to see if it's a thing I want to be a part of, it's a thing I'm curious about,
and so I gave it a whirl.
OnlyFans is catching on during the COVID-19 quarantine.
The company told Forbes that it's getting a hundred and fifty thousand new users a day.
It's a relatively straightforward way to make a little money from erotic photos and videos.
I'm experimenting so I posted videos of me twerking in a thong, just like pictures of my butt in lingerie,
pictures of my butt without lingerie. I'm still trying to figure out like what exactly I want it to be.
What Reisenwitz and new OnlyFans users are engaging in lives under the big umbrella that covers sex work,
though OnlyFans has gotten some mainstream attention during COVID-19,
a number of sex workers found their way to the site and web sites like it years ago.
It's just another tool for navigating a world that stigmatizes and outlaws parts of their work,
but it's also a milestone in the story of how sex workers use the Internet's many technological devices
to thwart middlemen advice police to ply
their trade in safer and more autonomous
ways so many more women are able to be
their own producers now Constance Penley
is a professor at the University of
California Santa Barbara in the early
1990s she and her colleagues sought to
get pornography the same study as other
mediums in the film and Media Studies
Department since then she's taught a
porn 101 class
researched its history and importance to
culture with the rise of camming there's
been an extraordinary power shift in the
industry away from studios away from
bigger producers the bigger agents
distributors and now it's much more in
the hands of people who may perform in
adult industry films but that's not the
main part of their living do you know
anything about the history of webcam is
it is there like a I am the living
history of webcam no but truly I mean I
I was doing analog webcam at the lusty
lady theater in San Francisco's like
2009 Suzie Q's career tracks with the
very transition Penley has been writing
about she started her career at the
lusty lady theater a strip club owned by
strippers it's a job that I got right
out of the recession I had my liberal
arts degree in hand and I was no longer
gonna put up with retail and things got
a lot better people literally walked in
off the streets and opened a door put a
dollar in the slot and saw my naked body
and we had a conversation through glass
but the peep show was failing we weren't
getting the money we were not hitting
the numbers we were all making like just
above minimum wage aside from what we
could hustle from our individual like
private shows then a pornographic
website called kink.com was looking for
webcam performers I was one of the first
generation of kink live girls you would
get scheduled you had a PA on set so you
had a full king comm set there was like
the bordello that had like a cow skull
in it a stripper pole there was the
medical set it was a whole deal and it
was a completely unsustainable business
model so that shutdown leaner sites came
but the payouts weren't always high
enough to make it a priority for
performers meanwhile Suzy Q saw the rise
of social media platforms in real time
happening all around her in San
Francisco and Silicon Valley most of my
clients were Silicon Valley tech
industry folks I had a podcast I was
really interested in this intersection
between technology and sex work then in
2011 a new app debuted in the app store
now
chat was the first platform we had that
had content that would disappear that
you can kind of eat and it was so
illicit like you just wanted to send a
dick back it just it begged for it right
podcasting was another technology with
low barriers to entry that allowed Suzy
Q to interact with her fans and get paid
directly I had a way for people to have
a recurring monthly charge on PayPal
that would then support the podcast or
get them access to premium snap feed or
whatever then came mainstream camera
sites that offered similar autonomy
allowing performers to keep about 70 to
80 percent of what they earned through
tips and private messaging part of Suzy
Q's webcam business is done through a
website called model Centro which owns
Phan Centro it generally works the same
way as only fans the model Centro really
created essentially the adult industry's
Squarespace and the ability to just plug
and play your own site where you could
feature your own content and then users
can access that via their smartphones
that really changed the game camming is
just one part of a sex-workers business
performers also do studio films
stripping escorting making appearances
selling merchandise and even creating
Amazon wish lists the more eyeballs
means the more popularity and the more
popularity means the higher the rates
across the board there are ways in which
the workers in the adult industry have
to be even more creative in their
precarity than a lot of other people
because of the stigmatization because
the legal status and all of that but for
artists sometimes constraints can push
you to be more creative instead of
studio lighting cameras may use a desk
lamp instead of a set they may use their
messy studio apartment they must choose
between a stationary laptop camera shot
or go handheld on an iPhone currently
right now while we're in lockdown I feel
like everyone is creating their like art
or pornos science projects we're all at
home being like okay what do I got I got
the cell phone I've got this makeup
brush guess we're doing an awesome arm
rush to pass instruction you know it's
just like what it's such a creative
challenge
sex workers have always had to be
creative to survive before the
mainstream internet sex work was done
mostly on the street through pimps and
was dangerous but when sex workers got
online they were able to cut out the
middleman screen clients and create a
world for themselves that was more
lucrative and safer only fans and
websites like it are the latest chapter
in that story where sex workers get to
decide whom they let into their world
you can create even more authenticity
because you are speaking to someone you
are really letting that person on your
own terms of course completely on your
own terms into your life into your
creative space if I go live for only my
fans it's wonderful it's just like
hanging out with the gang hey guys I got
this new body wash let's see if let's
see you know it's funny I've been on
social media I'm like super active on
Twitter have been for a really long time
only fans is like the nicest place on
the internet for me right now and by a
lot to me and each other as far as I can
tell like I get compliments I get money
like it's it's nice we can make sex what
we want it to be and there's nothing
wrong with that there's nothing shameful
about that it's a beautiful thing to
make meaning of our own sex lives
you